hey guys Pete here will give you my full
recap and review for Twin Peaks season 3
episode 10 laura is the one if you're
not caught up this is your spoiler
warning this will spoil everything up
until part 10 of 22 the return I'm going
to do a theme by scene first and then a
discussion about things after so there
will be a timestamp link in the
description if you want to skip over the
scene by scene so we start out in Twin
Peaks itself or somewhere on the
outskirts I would guess and we see
Richard pull up at a trailer that we
eventually find out is Myriam he has a
beat-up car has some different color
panels on it so we could see that he's
not living a high life style as of you
know as a result of his drug dealing but
he pulled he comes up to the door calls
her name she wants him to go away
and she says that she has already told
the cops that he killed the little kid
but she doesn't know why he's not been
arrested yet so she mailed a letter to
sheriff Truman and he wants to know
about that and it turns out she mailed
it that day so he goes into a rage bust
the front door gets inside we don't see
what happens in there but he hits her
with something it looks like and we see
him light a candle after he turns on the
oven and he leaves and he calls Chad
deputy Chad on the way out it doesn't
mean needs him to intercept that letter
Chad seems pretty much like Chad always
does kind of sounds bothered by the fact
that he's even calling him but he agrees
to do it and it's interesting the day
when they pan down on the body of Miriam
she was definitely still breathing
there's also I guess he you know he's
trying to blow up the trailer but he
also kicked out the door so there would
be ventilation there a lot of people
have mentioned she may not die but she's
also out in the middle of nowhere so who
knows you know I mean but it may have
botched the murder we don't know for
sure then we get a nice little
transition team where harry dean stanton
scholar rod is playing red river valley
on the guitar it's cool i mentioned it
in the top moments videos go into too
much here but yeah it was awesome and
then we hear the
even and Becky fighting but what we see
is really just Steven yelling at her and
her kind of rolled up in a ball on the
couch you don't see him hit her but it's
obvious that he's pretty unhinged she
said something what from what I can
gather she said something about what he
does or what he's doing because he's
going on about how much money she makes
why she doesn't ask for a raise and then
he says I know exactly what you did but
we don't know for sure what they're
talking about after that we see
broadening mitchum in his let me room I
guess it is he's doing some paperwork
from surveillance at the casino signing
off on stuff kandi comes in chasing a
fly and I've already talked about this
in the top moments but she's a trip like
I don't know what's going on with her
we'll talk more about her later I guess
but yeah she's following a fly around
she ends up hitting him in the face with
a remote control and this is a source of
trauma it draws some blood and Jim
Belushi who plays the brother Mitchum
comes in and yeah it just sort of sets a
tone of us not knowing what the hell is
going on with the showgirls that call of
these two around but they're obviously
in their employ but we don't really know
one why they wear showgirl outfits all
the time and to why they have such
strange personalities from there we go
to the doctor's office and the doctor is
surprisingly uninterested in the changes
that have happened with dougie since the
last time he saw him dougie coupe is
obviously in a lot better shape than the
original dougie Jones was so his wife
Jane EE takes notice of this and this is
another thing I talked about before but
it's still funny to watch I just
rewatched it and the way that she gets
that little twist of her lips there is
just hilarious
so yeah nothing really happens of note
at the doctor's office he doesn't see
the bullet hole that you know agent
Cooper should have he doesn't want to
check to see if he there's something
wrong with his brain he just sends them
on his way as far as we know we do find
out though that agent Cooper has perfect
blood pressure next we go back to Ben
and Rodney Mitchum's place we can see
that candy has not
covered from the term uh the dramatic
experience of hitting Rodney in the face
she's bawling she's inconsolable
he eventually turns on the television
and they see that IQ spike has been
arrested then mentions that they can
save a bunch of money now because they
have a hit on Mike because they can call
it all they also notice dougie coupe
from the surveillance camera footage
from the casino
and now they know who he is we also see
a we I mean we see that these guys are
vicious guys but then we also see this
weird side where candy says how can you
ever love me after what I did and we can
see that they kind of just put up with
it like they we don't know why or what's
going on but it's interesting to note I
think but we get the replay of Jamie E's
description on the television and that's
pretty funny
and Cooper cracks me up because he he
goes to touch the the badge and I don't
know why that I found this hilarious
next we go back to the Joneses house and
we can see that the trip to the doctor's
office has really gotten Janie II going
this is hilarious because she's super
into it and she asked like am i
attractive do you find me attractive and
he's eating a chocolate cake like a
piece of chocolate cake and I don't know
it's really funny the dougie stuff in
this episode was actually really good
and he obviously doesn't respond when
she says I think you're attractive he
just goes back to eating the cake and
it's pretty it's pretty classic all the
way around eventually she gets them
upstairs they have a pretty intense sex
scene where dougie coupe is pretty much
flapping his arms and enjoying himself
Jeannie II is definitely enjoying
herself as well and they wake up sonny
jim and everybody seems to except for
probably sonny jim everyone seems to
have enjoyed this little session we have
our first visit with dr. Jacoby in a
while or should I say doctor am he is
ranting about the government I just
watched again and was trying to find out
if there was anything really specific
but it seems just like he is pissed and
I don't know that we're supposed to take
anything else away from that except for
that he is really pissed off at the
government he talks about a lot of
different things and we see Nadine is
watching from her run silent run Drake
stop when I first saw this I was like oh
she's successful but I guess when we
think about it it's not really
guaranteed because she has a shop that
she's successful she did get her idea
off the ground though that much is clear
there's a weird display out front where
it automatically opens and closes the
drapes so that you can see one of
Jacobi's golden shovels and yeah I'm not
sure what the trajectory of these two
characters are but she is absolutely
mesmerized by him and he's basically
just angry at the man for lack of any
better way to describe it
after that we go back to the Joneses and
we see them leaving the house in the
morning Jamie is still very pleased with
Dougy coop from the last evening and she
steals a little moment to give him a
kiss and tell him she's still thinking
about it
he still pretty much looks the same to
me I don't notice any major change from
what happened there but we don't get to
see much of him either they just sort of
sneak a kiss and then go off to the car
we find out that Gerry is still out in
the woods he's still wearing the same
clothes they said the same background
teams they showed last time but I'm not
sure that means anything about where
he's at currently I mean it's a mountain
so he could be anywhere you could see
that we see that he is trying to do
something with his phone but he has no
service and he's really frustrated and
he screams you can't pull me I have been
here before let me go back over to the
Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department and Chad
comes up front
Lucy asks him what he's doing there and
they make small talk about what a
beautiful day it is or at least he
attempts to make small talk about that
Lucy sort of rambles a strange thing
about time and about one turn Andy heads
or Andy had thought that the clock had
stopped but then they realized they
didn't even know what time it was
and then the mailman starts to come so
chad cuts it off and goes outside he
intercepts the mail the mailman thinks
this is weird
because he's waiting for him to drive
away Lucy's trying to sort of spy on the
situation and see what's going on
but he finds a letter that he thinks is
the right one I did in a shirt pretty
good and then comes back inside takes
another doughnut and walks away whether
he got the right one or not isn't clear
I'll talk about that later but as far as
what we saw he grabbed the letter that
he was looking for we had a quick scene
of Richard horn driving and he gets the
text message from Chad saying that it's
done and then we go over to the house
where we saw Johnny run and crash his
head into the wall we find out that he's
okay more or less but he's restrained in
a chair wearing a helmet and he has this
bear was sort of a robot II kind of head
on top of hit and it just says hello
Johnny how are you today over and over
again now I read that this face on this
is related to something else that David
Lynch did I haven't seen it but a lot of
people have brought that up but
basically he just sits there and I guess
the bear calms him down in some way or
another he never answers the question
obviously but that's what he's doing
then we hear over the intercom that
Richard is pulling up Sylvia tries to
stop him from coming in but that's not
really going to work and we get this
brutal scene where he chokes her
threatens her gets the combination to
her safe takes all the money and
everything else of value and the house
puts it in her purse and takes off
Johnny is upset and trying as soon as he
comes in Johnny reacts but obviously
he's restrained so there's nothing he
can do we see that is what his jaw looks
to be wired shut like he broke his jaw
Sylvia mentioned that then won't give
him money anymore his grandfather so we
do that Richard's a pretty horrible
human being all the way across the board
it's a rough scene to watch Johnny's
bear and the background makes things
even more eerie and
but Richard makes off with some loot and
we see Silvia go to Johnny on the floor
after that we head to Las Vegas we see
Duncan Todd in his office his assistant
Roger comes in to tell him that it is
true that it's all over the news Ike the
spike has been caught we see the tony
anthony sinclair is there Todd calls him
over we find out a couple interesting
things here primarily that now it is
Tony's responsibility to go convince the
Mitchum brothers that dougie Jones is
the reason that they lost that insurance
claim for thirty million dollars and to
get them riled up by saying that Doug he
has a vendetta against them so that
they'll take care of dougie themself the
other thing is he mentions that
insurance claim that we conspired to
shut down so Duncan refers to the
missions as his competitors and
bitterest rivals but we don't exactly
know what that means but we do know that
Tony helped him do something dirty and
now he's going to have to do this or
else and no uncertain terms mr. Todd
says that he'll have to kill dougie
himself get a quick sequence and see
that Albert is out on a date with
Constance the coroner they seem to be
having a great time and Gordon and Tammy
are looking in and they are enjoying it
as well so it's a cute team we don't
really find out anything they're looking
from a distance so we can't hear what
they're talking about but it looks like
they're just having a normal date and
that they're really enjoying each
other's company we return to the silver
Mustang casino and we see Tony Sinclair
has arrived and security cameras the
Mitchum's send candy to go pick him up
and bring him back and it is pretty
hilarious
at first he doesn't answer and I'm not
sure if it's because Rodney sang your
name and then she doesn't answer until
Ben does or whatever but yeah so she
goes and we see this all in the security
camera we see it from like their
perspective and we see them in the frame
so she gets down there and it's like a
full minute and five seconds of her
doing this stuff like she's moving her
around pointing places and doing
different things before they break and
they call down and say get her up here
both of their faces are hilarious
watching her is hilarious and it's a
really great scene I under appreciated
it the first time I watched it for sure
so anyways he gets in there they talk he
does what he's there to do he tells them
that it was actually dougie Jones that
has the vendetta
they don't give much up they pretty much
listen and say is that it and have him
go he sort of drives the point home
because he doesn't obviously want to
kill dougie himself and then when they
go home and the next scene we see that
they are very moved by the information
this pair is awesome I mean this is a
really cool thing here when they're
talking the acting is really good and
it's funny as well because when it comes
down to is they want to have dougie they
won't have a meeting with him they
mention how much money they're out
because of him not only for the
insurance but for the casino winnings
but then the Jim billet near Ben Jim
Belushi says you [ __ ] us once shame on
us you [ __ ] us twice
shame on you you're dead so yeah it was
cool from there we head on over to
Gordon Cole's hotel room he's drawing a
nice little illustration there that
still makes me laugh every time I see it
and he hears a knock on his door so he
goes over and when he opens it he sees
Laura Palmer not like she's actually
there but he sees her image this is a
clip from when she went over to Donna's
to ask her if they were best friends
like Donna are you my best friend it's
really interesting it's put together in
an interesting way there's a lot of
layers to the sound it sounds like you
know there's a music playing there's
some sounds from that original run stuff
and there could be some other background
noises there I don't know that sounds
like some popping whenever I'm listening
to it but that image fades away and we
see Albert there he kind of takes a look
back to make sure there's not something
behind him because of Gordon's look but
he comes inside he has info on Diane her
phone picked up a text message that
morning it's the one that we saw the
around the dinner table the conversation
is lively one explains to Gordon
that they thought since it came from a
Philadelphia cell tower that it was
probably one of her boyfriends but she
responded saying they have Hastings he's
going to lead them to the site this was
an encrypted message so they look closer
at the cell tower chain and realizes
that it came from Mexico to the
Philadelphia Tower Gordon says I felt it
when she hugged me and this confirms it
but we don't really 100% know what he
means there I mean the easiest option is
that he's saying that he knew she was on
the other side but I don't think we
could jump to that conclusion just yet I
think we need more information
I'm not even sure who that you know that
text came from like we talked about
before so anyways as they're doing that
Tammy comes to the door she has news
from the investigation on the glass box
and murders in New York City and she has
this photograph that has evil coupe it's
from the early cards from the recordings
of that place and he's talking to a
mysterious person who I have no idea who
it is like people brought up why wasn't
this part of the moments mainly because
I have no idea who he is like he's not
someone we've seen before and I don't
have much clues I mean obviously he
looks to be involved with setting up
this space so that leads you kinda to
the search for the zone website and some
of the stuff that was on there and
honestly the best theory I've heard
about this was that it is the other
person mentioned on the website like it
says that the site is put together by
Bill Hastings primarily but every once
in while this guy
Heinrich beagle contributes there's no
noticeable contributions from him on
there and he's really an enigma and
that's why this is a good theory because
he's a name that we've heard there's
stuff on that website that is relatable
to what's going on in New York and
that's really it we know nothing about
him and we know nothing about the guy in
the picture so it could be that guy but
it could be anybody else at the same
time so it's definitely interesting
mysterious and confusing Gloria just
says this is something this is really
something and there's not a lot of over
clue
there as to what else is going on some
people have mentioned that I was a third
person there but I only see two I think
there's some cables or some other sort
of thing next to him that just kind of
looks like there's another person there
after that we see Ben Horne getting a
call from Sylvia about what happened
we noticed that Sylvia no longer lives
at the Great Northern but this kind of
shows that they are separated he's still
wearing his wedding wedding ring in the
scene but she's talking about him
replacing the money he says he's not
going to send her anymore so there's
that back and forth and then whenever he
gets off the phone he says to Beverly
will you have dinner with me so he's
kind of lost his resolve not to fool
around with her after that we get the
log lady and her message for Hawke I
went through this whole thing in the top
moments video so I'm not going to repeat
the whole thing here I've been thinking
about the last couple of days and if the
timeline is the same I'm guessing that
this has something to do that with
what's going to happen at Jack's
Jackrabbits palace she talks about the
dream of time and space she tells them
to watch and listen time and space are
dimensions so I don't know
let's later us to see what you guys
think about this I haven't read any
great theories about it to this point
I'll be looking into it two more though
so yeah from there we cut to the road
house and we get a musical outro and the
episode ends so there is a lot of stuff
that happened here some of the main
points that are well first of all if you
just skip the scene my team welcome to
the video but some of the main things
are obviously Richard and deputy Chad's
conspiracy it seems very strange that
she had told the police about Richard
and they hadn't done anything yet so we
have to kind of guess that she probably
told Chad and he covered it up but then
we have this letter and there is a
problem with what we've seen the credit
the name in the credit for Miriam do not
match the name on the letter that we saw
there's two different last names
but there's also two
sheriff Truman so she said she looked
sent the letter to sheriff Truman but
did she mean Harry or Frank and did she
send to the police station or did she
send it to Harry wherever he is so
there's a lot of stuff there I did
mention that she could or could not be
dead based on what we saw but either way
it doesn't seem like Richard is covering
much up and that's what we're supposed
to take away from that he's reckless we
don't know what's going on with the
investigation about the hit and run I
mean that is kind of bizarre that we
haven't heard about that again but
something has to be coming in relation
to all of this
Richard Horne stop the Diane stuff it's
a big revelation but I'm just not a
hundred percent sure we know what's
going on as far as who she's in contact
with in what Gordon sensed when she
hugged him I mean obviously the most
clear explanation would be that she is
working with those guys but you know her
message said they have bill Hastings
he's going to take them to the site so
what exactly at this point is the site
is it where he met the major and if
that's the case why would it be relevant
right at this moment we haven't really
heard evil cou talk about heading back
in that way for anything so yeah it's
not really clear I was reading a lot of
stuff about all the different murder
plots that have been hatched against
Doug Lee since you know we have this we
now know that things are in motion for
the Mitchum's to take him out but like
basically since we saw the switch and
Evil coupe has been inhabiting Dougie
Jones's life we have just seen a
situation where there are people trying
to kill his incompetence settled at all
times well I guess we learned he's not
100% incompetent because he did stop
Ike's attempt but yeah it's pretty crazy
I'm sure the Mitchum's are going to have
to move it'll be interesting to see what
happens there I like those two
characters I hope we get a little bit
more of them the guy in the box like I
said who's at the box with evil coupe I
really don't know does this mean that
evil coupe set up the box or does it
mean that that guy set up the box and
evil coupe went there to visit no real
way to know and it all brings us back to
the idea of what does Gordon actually
no you know we found out quite a bit of
stuff in the secret history about him
knowing about listening post alpha and
what was going on there
basically all a major Briggs's work
everything blue rose related so how far
ahead is he compared to us like how much
more does he actually know and how is
that going to play out I'm really not
sure so let me know what you guys
thought what series you're kicking
around please like the video if you
enjoyed it as always please subscribe to
my channel I'll be doing the 10 things
you might've missed there was a couple
things I left out here that because
they're going to be in that so I'm not
completely oblivious but I want to this
video is long enough but I wanted to
talk about some of those things a little
bit more separately please follow me on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram I
post regularly I'm most easily
accessible on Twitter but as you know I
try to answer the comments as best I can
as well so that's it thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon